I feel like Microsoft has two lanes that
they got approved for this this game
start for they got to justify the
beginning of all these these you know
these purchases which is but as to why
we bought Bethesda we bought Bethesda
for games like Star Phil uh you know
then they got to prove that you know not
only did we buy Bethesda because I I do
think they have to prove two people why
they're investing so much money into the
ecosystem they also got approved and
we're gonna actually help make a better
Bethesda we're we're gonna hear the
Fallout 76 illness that they have and I
think that these two lanes are very
rough to navigate through and all it
would take is this game come out in a
real bad state they're like okay it
don't matter they bought Bethesda they
they're going to make nothing but
Fallout 76 for the rest of our lives and
if the game comes out then okay it
doesn't matter they invested what's the
point in investing into Activision
investing